take a look at uh
dylan's numbers on this season brought
to you by the pennsylvania lottery
you know not a lot of work so far just
uh 14 innings but
four walks 10 strikeouts that's a good
number for sure era is
great shape and
hopefully that's the first out
and there's that fastball you talked
about hoy park two hands it
[Applause]
oh how about his change up
impressive cabrera 248 hitter on the
season he's approaching 3 000 hits
continues to climb up the all-time list
and so many offensive categories he
brian hayes
has all day to throw to first and one
two three for dylan peters willie's
making his 15th appearance and 14th
start at 2021 has that three and three
record
with a 3-6-8 e-r-a
and lined into right center field he's
got it going again
with that opposite field attack isn't he
101.8 hard hit by hayes september man
and just out in front pop-up hayes will
tag
grossman
will be cut off
so haze at third
with one out of the pitch
fly ball should be deep enough to give
the pirates the lead as grossman will
make the throw to second a sacrifice fly
for colin moran gives the pirates a
one-nothing advantage in the first
wow look at that
then watch the barrel of the bat
chambers got to go towards the ball out
of the corner of his eye he says oh man
it's a good thing he did dodge that
another 2-2
and he pops it up into shallow left
willy castro has it
peters went about six inches off the
plate off the inner edge of the plate
and got him to chase
boy another strikeout there's a good
change up set up by him throwing his
fastball on the inner edge of the plate
and off the plate he got him chasing on
that change up down in the dirt
live ball hit deep to right center field
and
off the base of the wall
oh michael perez
in the second base or the leadoff double
in the second inning
infield is in
plays at the plate and they got him
jamer candelario quick thinking perfect
throw and they're able to cut down
michael perez at the plate
key out there are two away here in the
second josie tsutugo stands in now
and sends one
to deep center field back goes derrick
hill and he's got it that's it
[Applause]
and you could hear people say nice catch
derek it's something that you're used to
ten pitches to get willy peralta through
the second one and one to derrick hill
ripped
by cabrian hayes and into the left field
corner
cut off by ben gammel
castro stutter steps his way around
third on his way home he's in there and
derek hill is safe at third base
tigers are on the board thanks to derek
hill and the speed and aggressiveness on
the base pass
top of the order for robbie grossman
61 runs driven in for grossman 2-2 to
grossman
a drive to left field and out of bounds
to gamble that'll drive in derek hill
the tigers have the lead on robbie
grossman's rbi single to left
fisted to center and out of the reach of
nico gooder nice play by scope moran's
going to try and score and he is out at
the plate
he didn't think anybody got to it but
jonathan scope was there to help
two strikes on hayes
he's running and the pitch swung on line
through the middle base hit alford tags
the bag and heads to third
on a hard hit single up the middle by
key brian hayes one and two you know you
want to get beat with your best pitch
got him sure did couldn't hold up and
peralta wiggles out of the jam he leaves
them loaded
with pirates here in the fourth
runner goes throw down is strong
call great throw by perez
fantastic job by michael perez
2-0
ground ball park
to newman
and on to moran for a double play
to left
long run gamble and gamble gets there
hold on to it he did
somebody check on that wall out there
what a great play by ben gamma i mean
we're spoiled by him
and gamma will step to the plate this is
a an opportunity here bases loaded the
pirates have stranded 10 men base hit
can score two here with two outs pirates
down one two to one in the sixth here's
the pitch
ground ball base hit now big ben struck
one he struck two
and the pirates take the lead
on the two run single by ben gamel
staking his claim on hero of the night
yeah he is
there's the one two to cabrera
pulls his hands in and lines it down the
left field line and that's gonna be a
ground rule double
to lead off the eighth from miguel
cabrera i think he's done an excellent
job of hitting the off-speed pitch
big chase
two outs
and a bouncing ball one hopper
well done
[Applause]
the renegade puts up a scoreless top of
the eighth pirates still up by one
this time it's the second pitch that he
connects
and drills to left field for a lead-off
single there's the start that you wanted
here's the o2 got a swing gonna miss he
struck him out
stratton strikes out hill for the first
out in the ninth inning
got him
looking right at the knees with the
fastball
back to back k is for stratton
[Applause]
and in the air to center
raise the jolly roger
back-to-back games and chris stratton
it's right back on that horse
and earns the save and what a night for
ben gamble that ben just did a heck of a
job tonight
you